we're here with vaseline topalov he just
won a crazy game against ivan sarge
ruslan take it away what happened
well uh apparently my knowledge is a bit
outdated because uh i believe that
uh what he did
at the beginning playing with the bishop
on e6 was dubious but apparently
apparently
i mean
ever since i started this line i it was
considered not so good but apparently
there are new lines and uh
it also works
so okay somehow i don't know because
here
uh that's critical and now d5 so okay of
course i could also
uh
play the mo
i thought also
here
uh
queen h3 also looked interesting but
somehow i was not so sure what to do
after castling i think
so okay for example here
um
somehow the move h6i i was not so sure
about also about uh
well one second
here after
ef
94
yeah well now
white has a very good positional
uh advantage but there's a lot of
dynamic and
also many people pieces are hanging so i
don't know uh now it should be good for
black
but uh what i missed was that well i
missed many moves but
my original idea was different here not
to place um
c3 i think
was maybe uh yeah i thought i should go
somehow my idea was to exchange the
queen somehow by playing uh
i think there was some move
uh but
but c3 is probably just dubious
and now suddenly
what i missed was that um
after queen d5 of course i my plan was
to go queen d3 maybe or i don't well
probably queen d3 was my plan but there
was a move i
uh and then
trying to exchange the
you know so if he takes then i go queen
c2 this is this was that was my idea
to go like this
so if black takes my idea was to go like
this and then exchange pieces so i
thought okay with the knight on e4 black
white has a good position i don't know
if it's
but a 95 uh yeah knight e5 queen d4 no
and maybe
and then he just goes to the yeah right
so maybe i can
trade my queen and then
play knight d4 but apparently it doesn't
work because black has checks yeah so
there's a lot of dynamics and
and it looked pretty
pretty
dubious for me i have to admit but
suddenly i'm lucky that uh
here
after d3 uh
well no in fact my idea was to go
something like rook d2 but then i saw it
was just not working and i i had to
play plan b which was b3 and now knight
g3 i have to admit that it looks very
dubious because
because
white king is totally unprotected but
for the moment it is true that uh
uh okay rook d3 obviously is the
critical move and then
uh
i thought that okay there are many many
uh so that's my my uh
right and then c4 yeah this is what uh
that's very nice thanks yeah c4 but
that's not the end because uh apparently
there was some move like taking right
and then he goes like this c3 that's
crazy with the check right now
then
maybe just
winning for black
if he well no you pick up both pieces
exactly because i
uh
exactly because here i'm oops that's
right i'm on time to uh first take on c6
uh and then
white is winning but uh yeah
and then uh
so queen e5
it's it felt wrong because black doesn't
really
have any
threads but i played knight f1 because
okay i saw a move like this
but
something like this take
so
knight takes d2 right and then i thought
that black takes
here uh check this looks scary here and
i i somehow didn't know what to do now i
thought it was kind of perpetual right
uh because if i go like this yes check
black has checked so maybe it wins
because i go up yeah maybe it was just
winning but
but going up the board yeah but
somehow it felt bad because
and that's that's the reason i play
knight f1 because my idea was to simply
slowly collect the d2 pawn with uh and
keep all the control and i thought that
also queen g3 is good and i couldn't see
also knight g3 is also an idea so
i thought it was a good move simply not
maybe not the best but uh solid enough
we were both in time travel uh
and then okay this is just uh not good
because now
uh
okay the rook is away and black has to
either
black goals for hopeless ending
or uh keeps the queen but then i just
collect all the pawns from the from the
queen's
there was one little trick here i think
that here
uh i took i think
and my and now i took again
so it look it's so okay i don't know
about this move but
somehow i got scared about
this
and then i don't uh
let me see
here
here but of course
of course it is true that my queen is on
g4 somehow i thought it was on uh g2
because
actually the black queen was there so i
started looking at all these checks but
of course it's just hopeless i can just
go here and maybe not so clear intuition
ah then you just check yeah it goes
check or you play according to the
engine rook h yeah yeah like it could be
but maybe
it was a bit strong yeah still it's so i
just made a solid move because i felt
like black has zero uh you know all the
pieces are misplayed and i'm uh all
endings are winning so i don't need to
uh calculate this and of course um
otherwise it's already easy yeah
vaseline it seems like you're seeing a
lot of tricks you're seeing a lot of
stuff
what's missing to score a couple more
points well no not really because for
example the first date uh first game
today uh i made a move and then simply
uh i thought my queen was on c on c8 but
it was actually on b8 so i'm seeing some
moves but of course i'm also missing
very simple
um
moves like for example against magnus
the game i lost uh i simply didn't
realize he could take my bishop and okay
it was
not
not decisive because uh the mistake i
made was later on but okay the very fact
you miss such simple moves that uh how
the night moves it's quite disturbing um
no i'm not really playing well but uh
the truth is i okay it's uh
uh i'm not really
trained i didn't come uh with any
training for this and uh but again i'm
enjoying the organization it's really
great and for me first time in croatian
i really enjoy it feels like you're
getting better and better the more the
tournament gets in uh well okay
at least i think i scored today the
maybe the i had so many good positions
against my majero completely winning
also game one against uh
maxima i was at some point clearly
better okay but of course it was
complicated so uh so today i probably
won the most um
undeserved game from those i played well
it still was a fight and you came out
ahead so congratulations on that one one
more rapid game you think you're gonna
try to get the blitz to catch up uh well
you know the open opening ceremony i
said that uh i like blitz but i thought
my rapid chest was better and it's a
total disaster so imagine how blitz is
but
no it's just around i sometimes i mean
if i kind of free my hand and play the
natural moves i have chances i believe
oh absolutely you're such a fantastic
player thank you for taking the time to
explain this game in detail we'll let
you go one more rapid game left good
luck yeah thank you thank you wrestling
guys back to the studio in st louis last
round of the rapids remember counts for
double very important and here we have
our standings after round 8